JOHN ESSIGMANN: At the end
of the course, when there's
so many pathways out there that
things start to get really,
really complicated,
we try to increase
the number of
physiological scenarios,
again, to try to get the
students sufficiently
interested in a
pathway and thinking
about how the whole
pathway works,
not just each individual step--
to get the student to like the
example so that he or she will
go right in there and study it.
And one of the areas that
I think really important
these days in basic
metabolic biochemistry
is in oncology-- cancer biology.
JoAnne mentioned that
not that many years ago,
academic programs
wondered whether teaching
metabolic pathways was
really the best use of time,
because so many
other things were
happening in the molecular
biology revolution.
And certainly in 5.07 we decided
to maintain emphasis in this,
because we--
just because these are the
first pathways that were studied
doesn't mean they
aren't important.
They're medically
very important.
They were originally
studied because
of medical or economic
reasons that--
fermentation, for example--
that these pathways
were right in front and center.
They're always very topical.
But what happened in I'd
say the last 10 years
is that there's
been a reawakening
of the understanding of how
metabolic pathways redirect
themselves in order to
accomplish disease goals--
for example, with a tumor.
And one of the things
we teach is that a tumor
is a lot like a running muscle.
And Matthew Vander Heiden,
who is here in our biology
department and teaches
the comparable course
is a real expert, a
pioneer in this area.
But what we've learned
is that cancer cells
tend to be addicted to glucose.
They would much prefer
glucose over any other fuel.
In fact, they-- when you think
about what a cancer cell really
is, it's a cell
that's not terribly
different from all
our other cells.
It's acquired some
small number--
we'll call driver mutations,
maybe seven or so driver
mutations.
There are many more passenger
mutations, but maybe
seven or so genetic
differences that
separate it from a normal cell.
But among the things
that has happened to
it is reprogramming of
its metabolic needs.
And it has acquired
the commitment
to unremitting cell division.
If you think about what's
needed for a cell to divide,
probably the principal
structural resource-- which,
again, this would come from
JoAnne's part of the course--
is membranes.
You've got to recreate the
outside of the cell and all
those organelles.
And what that means is
fatty acid biosynthesis
is absolutely going
to be paramount.
One way that we now know that
tumors work, if you understand
all the pathways, is a
tumor will consume glucose,
it will convert that
glucose to acetyl-CoA.
The acetyl-CoA takes a ride on
the molecule citrate until it
gets put out into the cytoplasm,
and then in the cytoplasm it
becomes a factory
for producing--
out of acetyl-CoA, it
produces the lipids
that are necessary
for membranogenesis.
That's absolutely critical
for cancer cell development.
Now, the reason that's important
is that understanding it,
it tells us that,
well, there are
certain enzymes in the pathway.
One of them is called
ATP citrate lyase.
Another one is
called malic enzyme.
So, when you look at the
charts, you'll see these things.
These are enzymes that are
necessary for cell division,
because they're necessary
for fatty acid biosynthesis,
and they represent
good targets--
next-generation targets--
for cancer chemotherapy.
A normal cell, you can
tell it not to divide,
and it won't divide.
But if you can tell a cell
that's committed to divide
and you tell it not to
divide, oftentimes that cell
will kill itself.
So by blocking these
critical points--
test points, we'll call them,
in this metabolic chart--
you're able to selectively kill
cancer cells-- we hope, anyway.
But this study of
metabolic biochemistry
has identified
these new targets.
Another thing that's, I
think, an important anecdote
about cancer cells is that
they need other cells in order
to survive.
If you think about the
problems that a tumor faces--
remember, it started
from a normal cell
that acquired new mutations,
converted into a cancer cell,
and then started to
grow out into a tumor.
As it grows, it becomes more
remotely placed relative
to the blood supply.
OK, now, certainly there
will be a response,
and the blood supply will try
to grow toward the tumor cells.
But the core of a
tumor is hypoxic.
It doesn't have enough oxygen
to do real respiration.
So, what happens
is, the cancer cell
tries to hard-wire the
glycolysis pathway to be on.
And rough estimates are that
through this-- initially,
a hypoxia-inducing factor, which
is a transcription factor-- you
get an upregulation by 10
to 20-fold of almost all
of the enzymes of the
glycolytic pathway.
So, what happens
is, the cancer cell
becomes a specialist
at glycolysis.
It does high-throughput
glycolysis-- glucose
to pyruvate.
But, again, we don't have
the metabolic equipment
to do a lot of--
we don't have the
metabolic equipment
to be able to do respiration
if you're removed from oxygen.
So, the pyruvate gets
converted into lactate.
Lactate gets pumped
out into the blood,
and, as I mentioned before,
it acidifies the blood.
That's what happens
with a working muscle.
But the tumor sends the
lactate into the blood.
It's picked up by the liver.
The liver is a specialist
in gluconeogenesis.
The liver then rebuilds
the lactate into glucose,
sends this back
out into the blood.
So, the tumor is then
able to re-eat the lactate
that it sent out.
So a partnership emerges
between the liver--
the gluconeogenic organ--
and the tumor.
So, the tumor finds
that it's fed by--
unwittingly-- by the liver.
And the liver is contributing to
providing the nutrition that's
eventually going to kill the
organism if something doesn't
go in to stop it.
But, again, understanding
the pathways
can give you ideas with
regard to how to intervene.
So, metabolic
biochemistry is pretty
critical to understanding
this generation's cancer
scientific agenda.